the Joe Rogan experience so we does like
one of the first things that we did is
make a really good help hemp protein
powder and when we were looking into it
look I can't even believe that you can't
grow this like doesn't do anything to
your consciousness zero it doesn't
affect you at all because it's related
to pot it's illegal the National hemp
museum is in versailles kentucky isn't
really where I graduated high school do
because it's Woodford County Kentucky
was at one point the largest him
producing Counting the entire nation
whoa it just I don't know something
about the limestone is total conditions
the humidity sunlight now shot in him it
was really really well Wow the first
legal 508 or acre hemp farm in Kentucky
unveiled so now it's legal in October oh
wow
so now they can grow it excellent
beautiful I don't live there anymore so
I'm out of touch but hey that's great
news that's fantastic news that's
amazing
well we're just talking about something
that I was gonna bring up oh [ __ ] I
can't remember something about something
about new mr. Nelson something new stuff
that had to do with with legalization
marijuana in Kentucky we were just
talking yeah yeah it's just it's just
pretty crazy that you'd have a hemp
museum and have it be illegal for so
long with no argument there's like
there's no science it doesn't pollute
anything it doesn't do anything the
environment the nation makes amazingly
built on it yeah everything was made out
of that [ __ ] do you ever see the first
Henry Ford Model T where he made the
fenders out of hemp and he's hitting it
with a hammer not know though dude you
had to watch this we'll play this for
you it's the craziest [ __ ] ever Henry
Ford's very first car that he made he
made the fenders out of hemp and you're
watching him hit this [ __ ] fender with
a hammer and a hammer is just bouncing
off the fender check this out
and this is crazy I mean I don't know
when was this what did it say Jamie was
the time it said their 1941 1941 so in
1941 before it was illegal so it was
made and it was made illegal right
around the time where
alcohol prohibition had ended and they
needed something to go after so then
they started using the same guys to go
after weed and this was pre that look at
this
he's hitting this [ __ ] thing with a
the back of an axe it's just bouncing
off it was also a great way to
discriminate against Mexican immigrants
it was and black people to the whole
name marijuana came from a Mexican slang
for a wild tobacco didn't have anything
to do with marijuana they just created
this thing like when they made it
illegal the the people that were they
didn't even understand they're making
hemp illegal they had all that explain
it to everybody then they were they had
like tax stamps that you had to but
about DuPont understood that all the
Institute's to the [ __ ] out of it so did
William Randolph Hearst that guy was the
craziest the guy whose Citizen Kane was
based on rules that guy was the craziest
so here is this guy's hitting this hemp
fender with a [ __ ] hammer Henry
Rollins testing it Henry Rollins goddamn
it look you barely smudged the thing I
mean they're so superior to metal and
it's easy it's a renewable resource like
we're we've [ __ ] this up so bad it's
so obvious it's one of the biggest
example said why are you drone on about
pot all the time it's because these
things like that are one of the biggest
examples of just how egregious making it
illegal is it is a it's one of the most
amazing plants we've ever discovered you
can make your house out of it
you can [ __ ] eat at you can get high
with it you can make your clothes with
it it has all the amino acids you could
use for heating oil you could what to
treat cancer patients treat cancer
patients with this here first I mean
somebody put it here come on come on
come on
right it helps reduce tumor size it's
crazy
helps a host of different diseases I
know a lot of people that have like
serious inflammation problems they smoke
some weed and they're alright just
lightens everything up and it's illegal
and you can grow it you grow your own
you can grow a [ __ ] ton of it in your
backyard anybody could do you have a
sprinkler okay
you got some good dirt alright you got
some weed that weeds just good to go
that's a [ __ ] hardy ass plant yeah my
grandmother she just had some some
health stuff and it's like you know how
do I you know she's pretty old-school
like well knowing there's this thing out
there that that isn't anything that
these doctors are gonna offer it's just
gonna make her feel awful yeah and and
you know ever have to go through all of
that somebody just give you comfort and
it ease nausea or make you want to eat
food or those kind of things like why
wouldn't you want someone you love and
care about to have that but then at the
same time you know you want to be the
person trying to feed pot to your
grandmother yeah it's a hard sell it's a
hard sell yeah it's just stunning how
well propaganda from 1933 carried all
the way the [ __ ] to 2018 it's stunning
is it I mean but it's almost a hundred
years yeah with what we like the amount
of information that you can get on a
subject now like say if you're the bet
the medical benefits of cannabis just
google that and you'll just start
reading all the [ __ ] like if it seems to
me that enough people would go wait what
are we doing like why is it illegal
nobody's died from it like no one more
people die of aspirin every year because
zero die from pot so it's really the
number zero it doesn't mean that people
are going to get high and walking at
traffic some some are gonna but I think
part of that is because we're not too
teaching people how to get high properly
someone gets high for them but it's time
you let a poner how many of those people
that are getting hit by cars are
actually looking at their phones it
could be a lot they were high and
looking at the phones
you don't see that here like you're
doing in Nashville I drove around and
that's like if I can't hate that and you
look every time was driving on a town
everybody's texting everybody's looking
down you can always spot on the
interstate
yeah we've been home but you don't see
that in California guys you guys have
like really heavy loss saw today yeah so
today some lady had drifted completely
in my lane and I looked over at her and
I saw the back of her head like I was I
was on the driver side I was on that
side looking over at her and all I saw
was the back of it she literally wasn't
looking at my car and she was just
looking
her phone and working her thumb and
occasionally like looking up at the
screen or looking up at the wind chills
like whoa you crazy lady
you think just cuz you're going 40 miles
an hour that's okay cuz you're on a side
street like you're not even looking
where you're going you driving a car
what if you hit a kid Jesus Christ
[ __ ] what if you slam into some old lady
you know what if you rear-end a bike
you're not even looking you didn't
notice the bike was there boom you run
over some guy's leg what in the [ __ ]
lady or dude maybe I was misgendering I
don't know I don't know what her
statuses you gotta be real careful today
Sturgill amazed it like that Nashville
is ever like super I don't know bro I
don't leave the house I really don't
have any idea I just I think that's a
good move yeah you know I like my kids
I mean I'm somewhat aware of everything
going on it's surprising that none of
that's really hit the music business mmm
as hard as it is but there's just yeah I
try to just do my thing
yeah there's a weird weird world were
living in today I would like I would
like us to figure this out better I
would like us to do just a little bit
better job being nice to each other
getting our [ __ ] together
you
[Applause]